Let's do one more homogeneous
differential equation, or
first order homogeneous
differential equation, to
differentiate it from the
homogeneous linear
differential equations
we'll do later.
But anyway, the problem
we have here.
It's the derivative of y with
respect to x is equal to--
that x looks like a
y-- is equal to x
squared plus 3y squared.
I'm writing it a little
bit small, so that I
don't run out of space.
Divided by 2xy.
So in all of these homogeneous
equations-- and obviously, we
don't know it's homogeneous
yet.
So we have to try to write
it as a function of
y divided by x.
So it looks like we could do
that, if we divide the top and
the bottom by x squared.
So if we just multiply-- let
me do it in a different
color-- 1 over x squared,
or x to the negative 2,
over 1 over x squared.
We're essentially just
multiplying by 1.
And then, that is
equal to what?
1 plus 3y squared over x squared
divided by 2-- if you
divide x, divide by x squared,
you just get a 1 over x-- so 2
times y over x.
Or we could just rewrite the
whole thing, and this is just
equal to 1 plus 3y over
x squared divided by 2
times y over x.
So yes, this is a homogeneous
equation.
Because we were able to write
it as a function of
y divided by x.
So now, we can do the
substitution with v.
And hopefully, this is starting
to become a little
bit of second nature to you.
So we can make the substitution
that v is equal
to y over x, or another way of
writing that is that y is
equal to xv.
And then, of course, the
derivative of y with respect
to x, or if we take the
derivative with respect to x
of both sides of this, that's
equal to the derivative of x
is 1 times v, this is just the
product rule, plus x times the
derivative of v with
respect to x.
And now, we can substitute the
derivative of y with respect
to x is just this.
And then the right hand side
of the equation is this.
But we can substitute
v for y over x.
So let's do that.
And so we get v plus x.
Instead of dv [? dv ?]
x, I'll write v prime for now,
just so that I don't take up
too much space.
v prime is equal to 1 plus 3v
squared, we're making the
substitution v is equal
to y over x.
All of that over 2v.
Now, let's see what we can do.
This is where we just get our
algebra hat on, and try to
simplify until it's a separable
equation in v.
So let's do that.
So let's multiply both sides
of this equation by 2v.
So we'll get 2v squared plus 2xv
v prime-- 2v times x, yep,
that's 2xv v prime-- is equal
to 1 plus 3v squared.
Now let's see, let's subtract
2v squared from
both sides of this.
And we will be left with 2xv v
prime is equal to 1 plus--
let's see, we're subtracting
2v squared from both sides.
So we're just left with a 1 plus
v squared here, right?
3v squared minus 2v squared
is just v squared.
And let's see, we want it to be
separable, so let's put all
the v's on the left hand side.
So we get 2xv v prime
divided by 1 plus v
squared is equal to 1.
And let's divide both
sides by x.
So we get the x's on
the other side.
So then we get 2v-- and
I'll now switch back
to the other notation.
Instead of v prime,
I'll write dv dx.
2v times the derivative of v
with respect to x divided by 1
plus v squared is equal to-- I'm
dividing both sides by x,
notice I didn't write the x on
this side-- so that is equal
to 1 over x.
And then, if we just multiply
both sides of this times dx,
we've separated the two
variables and we can integrate
both sides.
So let's do that.
Let's go up here.
I'll switch to a different
color, so you know I'm working
on a different column now.
So multiply both sides by dx.
I get 2v over 1 plus v squared
dv is equal to 1 over x dx.
And now we can just integrate
both sides of this equation.
This is a separable equation
in terms of v and x.
And what's the integral
of this?
At first, you might think, oh
boy, this is complicated.
This is difficult, maybe some
type of trig function.
But you'll see that it's
kind of just the
reverse chain rule.
We have a function here,
1 plus v squared,
an expression here.
And we have its derivative
sitting right there.
So the antiderivative of this,
and you can make a
substitution if you like.
You could say u is equal to 1
plus v squared, then du is
equal to 2v dv.
And then, well, you would
end up saying that the
antiderivative is just
the natural log of u.
Or, in this case, the
antiderivative of this is just
the natural log of
1 plus v squared.
We don't even have to write
an absolute value there.
Because that's always going
to be a positive value.
So the natural log of
1 plus v squared.
And I hope I didn't
confuse you.
That's how I think about it.
I say, if I have an expression,
and I have its
derivative multiplied there,
then I can just take the
antiderivative of the
whole expression.
And I don't have to worry about
what's inside of it.
So if this was a 1 over an x,
or 1 over u, it's just the
natural log of it.
So that's how I knew that this
was the antiderivative.
And if you don't believe me,
use the chain rule and take
the derivative of this,
and you'll get this.
And hopefully, it will make
a little bit more sense.
But anyway, that's the left
hand side, and then that
equals-- Well, this
one's easy.
That's the natural log, the
absolute value of x.
We could say, plus c, but just
so that we can simplify it a
little bit, an arbitrary
constant c, we can really just
write that as the natural log of
the absolute value of some
constant c.
I mean, this is still some
arbitrary constant c.
So we can rewrite this whole
equation as the natural log of
1 plus v squared is equal to--
when you add natural logs, you
can essentially just multiply
the two numbers that you're
taking the natural log of-- the
natural log of, we could
say, the absolute value of cx.
And so the natural log of
this is equal to the
natural log of this.
So we could say that 1 plus
v squared is equal to cx.
And now we can unsubstitute
it.
So we know v is equal to y
over x, so let's do that.
So we get 1 plus y over x
squared is equal to cx.
Let me scroll this down
a little bit.
Let's multiply both sides of the
equation times x squared.
We could rewrite this as y
squared over x squared.
So we multiply both sides times
x squared, you get x
squared plus y squared is equal
to cx to the third.
And we're essentially done.
If we want to put all of the
variable terms on left hand
side, we could say that this is
equal to x squared plus y
squared minus cx to the
third is equal to 0.
And this implicitly defined
function, or curve, or however
you want to call it, is the
solution to our original
homogeneous first order
differential equation.
So there you go.
I will see you in
the next video.
And now, we're actually
going to do something.
We're going to start embarking
on higher order
differential equations.
And actually, these are more
useful, and in some ways,
easier to do than the
homogeneous and the exact
equations that we've
been doing so far.
See you in the next video.